let's see if we can take the indefinite
integral of sine to the fourth or sine
of x to the fourth
this sine of x to the fourth
dx and like always pause the video and
see if you can work through it on your
own
so if this was a if we had an odd
exponent up here whether it was a sine
or cosine then the technique i would use
if so if this was sine to the third of x
i would separate one of the sine of x's
out so i would rewrite it as sine
squared x times sine of x and then i
would convert this using the pythagorean
identity and then when i distribute the
sine of x i'd be able to use u
substitution and we've done that in
previous example videos and you could
have done this if it was cosine to the
third of x as well or to the fifth or to
the seventh if you had an odd exponent
but here we have an even exponent so
what do we do
and so the technique we will use and i
guess you could call it a trick the
technique or trick to use is once again
you want to just algebraically
manipulate this so that you can use
integration techniques that we are
familiar with and in this case we would
want to use the double angle identity so
the double angle identity tells us that
sine
squared of x
is equal to is equal to one half times
one minus cosine of two x
cosine of two x so how can i apply this
over here
well our original integral is just the
same thing as
this is going to be the same thing as
integral of sine
of x squared all of that squared
dx
now i can make this substitution so this
this
this is the same thing as this which is
of course the same thing as this by the
double angle identity so i can rewrite
it as
i can rewrite it as the integral
of
one half
times one minus cosine of 2x
and then all of that squared
all of that squared
dx and what is that going to be equal to
that's going to be equal to well i see
one half squared is 1 4. so i can take
that out
so we get 1
times
the integral of
so i'm just going to square all of this
business
1 squared which is 1 minus 2
cosine of 2 x plus
cosine squared
of 2x
dx
d
x
now fairly straightforward to take to
take the
to take the indefinite integral or to
take the anti-derivative of these two
pieces but what do i do here well once
again i've got an even exponent let's
apply the double angle identity for
cosine
so we know that cosine
squared of 2x
is going to be equal to one-half times 1
plus
cosine of double this angle so cosine of
4x so once again just make the
substitution so this is going to be
equal to
this is going to be equal to actually oh
let me just write it this way 1 4
and i'll
maybe i'll switch well i'll just keep it
in this color 1 4
times 1 minus 2 cosine
2x
plus
1 half
i'll just distribute the one-half plus
one-half
plus
cosine
of 4x dx
cosine of 4x
dx let's see i could take this not that
one i could take
this one half and add it to this one and
that's going to get me three halves
so add those together i'm gonna get
three halves
and so let me rewrite this as i'm in the
home stretch really so this is going to
be equal to
1 4
times the integral of three halves
minus two cosine of 2x
and then
let's see the derivative of 4x is 4. so
it'd be great if i had a 4 out here so
let me write this let me rewrite one
half as 4 over 8. i'm just really i'm
just multiplying and dividing by 4 is
one way to think about it so i could say
plus
1 8
times
cosine
of 4x and i'm just doing this so that
it's well there you can do u
substitution but we've had a lot of
practice with this we'll say hey i have
a function i have its derivative i can
just integrate with respect to the 4x
right over there
so i guess you could say it's the
reverse chain rule which is really what
u substitution is all about and now i'm
ready to integrate so this is going to
be equal to i think we deserve a little
bit of a drum roll 1 4
times
3 halves x 3 halves x
see derivative 2x is sitting right over
here 2. so this is going to be minus
sine
of 2x we can verify this is the c
derivative of this is going to be 2
cosine of 2x if we have it right over
there
plus
plus 1 8
times well sine
of 4x derivative of sine of 4x is going
to be
4 cosine of 4x which is exactly what we
have there
and then home stretch we just write the
plus c plus sub constant this is an
indefinite integral and we're all done
this wasn't the simplest of problems but
it also wasn't too bad and it's
strangely satisfying to get it done